no men want sex 24 7. so why do we limit
it when men get married and get mad
mad when a desperate man cheats
so if you don't give your man sex do you
think he has a right to cheat
ladies
the floor is yours
[Music]
i wouldn't say
he has a right
but
if women don't know the saying like if
he's not getting it at home he's going
to get it somewhere else yeah then it's
like
like what did you expect yeah exactly
what did you expect if you're not
giving him what he needs and yes there
may be a ray of reasons why
you can't um
do one thing you can always do another
there's a
umpteen ways to please them
and so that's what i'm saying and like
obviously
that's different for every woman but i
don't i wouldn't give him i wouldn't
give him the right to cheat but i would
understand
it would suck and i'd be like dang maybe
i should have put it on a more but i i'd
be like if you're not getting it here
you're gonna fulfill that need somewhere
else would you leave him for it
no i wouldn't because
it was essentially
my
my cause that he went out and got it
from somewhere else now i just have to
reevaluate
when can i
like essentially
give him what he needs if i'm
super busy or whatnot or anything just
open up my mind and my understanding
to how a man a man operates and to what
he actually needs to be happy in the
relationship that was a long answer
what do you think
relationships are way more than about
just sex and i think um for women
[Music]
and men
i think that
relationships are
it takes it takes there's more things
in a relationship
where needs need to be met on both parts
yeah sex is one of them a massive one of
them
a big important part
um
but i don't think it's
it gives cause to give a man the right
to cheat because i might not be getting
my needs met in other areas of of life
does that mean
i go and cheat
because
my needs are not getting met no that
means we now need to come together
to talk and reason about where we're
going wrong
what things we can be doing more to
bring back more intimacy and more unity
in our mindsets so that
there isn't a breakup it's
yeah but if you're not if you're not
giving it to him i just don't how could
you be mad if you go somewhere else
i didn't say i'd be mad if you go
somewhere else i i probably would be mad
if my partner went somewhere else
because four times a week isn't enough
but did you tell me that four times a
week wasn't enough yeah maybe wouldn't
yeah he would have and that's in this
situation we didn't say how often you're
sleeping with him we just said it wasn't
enough we didn't say you were sleeping
with him but this is what i'm but this
is what i'm saying it depends on the
situation if i'm in a relationship and
no one's saying nothing
your needs are not getting met and i
have this is the first time hearing of
it is when i'm now finding out you've
cheated well i'm talking about there's
men that are in sexless marriages
where they haven't had sex in months and
then he cheats and then all of a sudden
she's crying on social media calling him
the bad guy but you didn't sleep with
him in months what was he supposed to do
do you think men are cheating more
because
society has been like over sexualized
though yes
no no i don't think so i think men have
been doing it as long as times are yeah
it's just more it's just more visible
now yeah oh yeah no the the cheating
rates are similar for men and for women
it's 25 and 28 percent so men cheat more
but what a three percent difference it's
nothing
and i don't think most men can cheat see
i can only speak from what i see and i
would say that's way off way off
in terms of who cheats more women are
men men women are better right
but men do it much more i don't know
i think society i think
depending on the way
what
depending on your demographic what
demographic you fit into i think society
is more bred for women to treat more
yeah women will always have more
opportunity because yes because of how
how men are yeah so
these three beautiful women can walk
down the street
every day and i guarantee at some point
someone will either look at them away
cap
yeah whatever it is so if your time's up
by two every day for a year they're
gonna get 700 opportunities to
make a movie yeah but we're the ones
pursuing like if you go i mean like
we're always the ones on the forefront
we can react to it but we're the ones
taking the action yeah the thing is
there's that top 20 though
it's that top 20 of men that are doing
the cheating
i don't know i've seen some hideous guys
cheating because cheating isn't just
about sex or lack of sex
cheating is also about
freedom discovering yourself learning
about different things that you want
having a sense of autonomy outside of
the relationship it's more it's about
having um
an emotional relationship sometimes it
is an animalistic i just want to [ __ ]
someone blah blah blah but i think in a
long-term relationship when someone
steps out it's more of an emotional need
that needs to get met for women as well
as that's the reason why you've done it
for women
i'm just asking
and i also think as well with those
stats with the women
i think that it would probably be higher
in women i would guess so too but i
think women lie about it yeah it's just
about to say because women minimize
sex whereas men exaggerate yeah
and the other is men women cheat because
they're not emotionally satisfied men
don't men just like
i've heard guys say that it was better
than my hand when referring to a girl
have you said that sarah why you
laughed no absolutely i've said that men
will have sex with a hole in the wall
yes yeah
anything they do
as i'm saying they do women
women only tend to step out more time
not all the time here but um when
someone's lacking on the emotional side
they want that affection or they want
that time or they want to be wined and
dined or made to feel like a queen or
whatever men we can just be horny and be
like i'm out with the lads they're
telling me to do it i'm going to do it
oh yeah that can happen as well they can
but not on the same magnitude yeah but
but women it's more because she's with
her second choice
she doesn't actually want the guy that
was her second choice
yes yeah because women cheat more
emotionally than men do don't they yeah
yeah no a girl a girl i'm sure at some
point
you guys have had a girl that's obsessed
with you like obsessed if a girl's
really into you she's not she's not
[ __ ] it up
i've never had to go to speedy
i think i think we also need to take
into account that men and women
women are biologically different like
women's
aim is to achieve or to claim the
highest valuable man they can so they're
less likely to have the mindset to want
to cheat if they believe they're with
the highest valuable man they've got
whereas men want to spread their seed
and therefore biologically they're
predispositioned to cheat and it's more
so have they got the discipline
or like the yeah the discipline to stop
themselves from doing so
i wanted to like ask a question though
like you see when it comes to
this generation and there's a lot of
like only fans
women around
as a guy
i'm looking at the future i'm thinking
at some point in time